it's now October which means all of you
Apple Fans should be getting hyped up
for another Apple event because out of
the last 15 years there have been 10
October events which is 66% of the time
so the chances are quite high so in this
video I'm going to tell you guys exactly
which brand new Apple products to expect
later this month as well as going
through all of the leaks and details we
currently have right now let's first
start with the Mac back in July Mark
Gman came out and said that the first M3
Apple silicon Max are likely getting
launched in October including the new M3
iMac the 13-in MacBook Air and 13-in
MacBook Pro yes that model that nobody
wants anymore with the huge bezels and
old design well apparently Apple's
updating it again and then just last
week a verified Source informed Mac
rumors that imminent changes are coming
to Mac trade in values suggesting that
that Apple will likely begin accepting
new models for tradein this month which
usually correlates with the launch of
new Mac products specifically around the
middle of October now if you think about
it it makes total sense for the M3 chip
to launch this fall because Apple
released the M2 Chip exactly 1.5 years
after the M1 chip which launched in the
fall of
2020 so if the M3 followed that cycle 3
years after the M1 would literally be
this fall perfect for an October event
and on top of that we know that Apple
gave the same M1 and M2 chips to the
iPad Pros around 6 months after they
gave it to the Max and we're expecting
new iPad Pros to come in the spring to
Summer of
2024 which would match the timelines
perfectly but there is just a little
problem M quo came out last last month
and said that the first MacBooks with an
M3 chip are unlikely to launch this year
at all so maybe that means we should
just expect an M3 iMac to launch or
maybe it means that the M3 launch will
get delayed even further until the
spring well I actually don't think so
because it would mean there would be an
almost 2year gap between the M2 and M3
chips which just doesn't make sense and
then that would have essentially further
delay both the M3 iPad Pro and the
high-end M3 Pro and M3 Max MacBook Pros
which Mark Gman has already leaked and
said he expects them to come sometime in
2024 likely the summer or the fall but
for this year based on all the data we
have I'm fairly certain we should be
seeing the launch of the M3 chip either
later this month or next month in
November it just makes so much sense in
terms of the timelines and Cycles
especially since Apple needs to have
enough time to release the M3 iMac as
well as the new 13-in MacBooks and now
with that said let's get into the other
two or three things we should be
expecting at this event and that's
basically a bunch of iPads but before we
get into that I want to talk about
something that's made my life a whole
lot easier over the past 6 months the
Mach V1 Ultra an all-in-one cordless wet
and dry vacuum that's been helping us
keep keep our kitchen and dining room
spotless unlike a Dyson that'll only
vacuum your floors the V1 Ultra vacuums
and mobs at the same time taking less
than half the time to get your floors
cleaned because the mop brush actually
cleans itself as it spins so you don't
have to constantly soak and ring out the
water like with manual mops it's been a
huge help since we have kids that
constantly drop or spill their food and
it even has a steam cleaning mode that
removes builtup grind and disinfects
with onboard ozone generated water and
auto miixed cleaning liquid with a final
selfcleaning mode that fully dries the M
brush my wife's absolute favorite use
case with the V1 Ultra has been cleaning
wet cereal or sticky rice which is by
far the toughest thing to sweep or mop
and the V and Ultra does it instantly as
well as cleaning up sticky messes like
syrup ketchup milk wet macaroni you name
it it works so well that we recommended
it to my sister-in-law with seven kids
including two twins and they use it
every single day so if you're interested
in ordering the vew and Ultra for
yourself or as a Christmas gift it's now
on sale for the lowest price all year
matching Black Friday on their Prime Day
promotion for $70 off on October 11th by
using the link in the description below
now back to the iPads while I'm not
expecting any major changes since that
will come with the iPad Pro next year I
am expecting some iterative updates to
the models M quo did come out last month
and say that the new iPads are unlikely
to launch this year but I'm honestly not
buying it how could Apple decide to not
release any M3 Max and not release any
iPads it just doesn't make sense in the
history of the iPad there hasn't been a
single s year where we didn't get a new
iPad launch so I'm 100% sure we will be
getting at least one iPad and on top of
that Apple has released a new budget
iPad every single year for the past 6
years without skipping a beat even when
the changes were so small like in 2020
when they simply swapped out the chip
for a powerful a12 and basically did
nothing else they still updated it so
this year I'm expecting a small update
to the budget iPad with a tiny change of
upgrading the chip from an A14 to an a16
ship and people are going to love it but
if you wanted more evidence than that we
just had a huge leak last week within
the second beta of iOS 17.1 the software
developer Steve Moser discovered a
reference to USBC charging for the apple
pencil this basically shows that apple
is about to update the original apple
pencil with a new USBC connector at the
back replacing the current lightning
connector which has no place at all and
doesn't make sense because the iPad 10
now has a USBC Port so you can't even
plug in the apple pencil for charging
like you used to do before it's a design
that doesn't make any sense at all
unless apple is going to release a new
Apple pencil with USB BC and maybe some
new features alongside it now moving on
to the other iPads we have even more new
leaks that are coming out which usually
only happens when a launch of new
products is imminent we just got a new
report claiming that apple is working on
two new iPad Air models code named j57
and
j58 which perfectly matches up to the
iPad air code name that Mark German
reported in June Apple is also appar ly
working on two more iPad Air models j53
7 and J5 38 but it isn't clear how those
ones will be different I'm personally
just expecting Apple to give the iPad
air6 an update to the M2 Chip which in
my opinion has to happen very soon
probably this month because the M2 iPad
Air absolutely must launch before Apple
reveals the M3 chip or else it's not
going to look good to to release an iPad
Air with the old M2 on top of that
Apple's recently been updating the iPad
Air every 1.5 years with the current
iPad Air 5 being released basically a
year and a half ago so the timelines
match up and on top of that the air
never gets updated alongside the iPad
Pro because these products kind of
compete with each other and since we're
expecting the iPad Pros early next year
the air absolutely must get updated this
fall now Mark German last month said
that the October event is unlikely but
even despite that he's still expecting
at least a press release of the iPad Air
refresh to happen this month so I'm
almost 100% sure that the air6 is coming
in October and finally we have the iPad
Mini 6 and I honestly think it's also
coming this month as well for a couple
of different reasons first of all we've
been seeing more and more leaks about a
refresh model like for example from Tech
Reeve on Twitter or X who says the
upcoming iPad Mini 7 will still come
with a 60 HZ display and second in 2019
Apple released both an iPad Air and iPad
Mini at the same time so they could
easily repeat that and do it again this
year and then finally it has now been
over 2 years since the release of the
previous iPad Mini 6 so if any IP AD
should be getting an update it's the
mini and I believe it's happening this
month with a simple chip swap to the new
a17 Pro chip just like in the iPhone 15
Pro Models this will make it really
enticing to upgrade since it's going to
be the perfect device for AAA gaming
with the new metal FX support R tracing
and more so with all that said that's
everything you should expect this month
even if we actually don't get an October
event and we get press releases instead
so hopefully you enjoy this video don't
forget about that crazy good deal for
the Mach V1 Ultra below thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video